voilà comment tout a commencé
françois mitterrand était avec un
nouveau président
et puis cette fille
la belge a vu un temps moi c'est des
bons muscles et noémie lui c'est mon
frère olivier
le roi de la pub mitterrand c'est un
produit du passé qu'il faut rendre
moderne un président brancher un
président chéreng tu sors et lui mon
pote sylvain le premier à avoir compris
à quoi sert vraiment un minitel viens je
te promets mille dennis lâche moi le
pain des pistes mais se prend pour
marguerite duras pas comme ça tombait au
plus mal ça vite avec ma mère monsieur
et moi journaliste sans concession pas
comme cegla tu t'y connais en
littérature ça va nous faire un portrait
de bernard henri lévy c'est quoi le
rapport entre les deux enfin sans
concession il faut le dire vite
aimez-vous l'esa en petites poires oui
non oui en fait durant ces années on
s'est tous un peu cherché
moi mon père je ne crois plus à la
gauche croit en dieu j'avais rien
d'autre en magasin mon frère c'est
capita part a cité
mais bon quand même comme
on n'a pas tous eu le même destin
mais on a tous rêver à des lendemains
qui chantent
c'était mon camp del qui se gèlent les
miches en direct du parc des sports de
bram